It's the most wonderful time of the year.
The 12,020 human space era calendar has arrived.
You can order it now until we sell out. And then never again,
in the last few years,
we've looked back at the achievements of our ancestors that paved the way for
our modern world. More than 10,000 years ago.
This year we'll turn our gaze to the future of humanity and how we will explore
space in the next 10,000 years,
12 illustrations will take you to the liquid gas oceans on tightened colonies on
Mars,
the storm clouds on Uranus and many more stops on humanity's biggest journey.
Yes.
Enjoy soda system-wide delivery shipping for the U S and finally,
also from Europe order now to get our limited edition calendar in time for the
holidays to make your kids, family, and friends happy,
or to distract yourself from the looming void within, you know,
whatever works for you. You can get the calendar together with a dunk, plushy,
a hoodie, or a poster. If you want, we've put together a few deals.
Thank you so much to the thousands of people who got to Canada last year,
because of you.
We can keep this channel free for everyone and make even more beautiful things.
A happy interstellar year, 12,020.